we're in a gynocentric social order now
so women think that and and
and guys that support whatever women
think without questioning it
think that well if female jealousy is
right
the right if female jealousy is related
to
insecurity well then male jealousy must
be
related into insecurity too so if you
have any feelings of jealousy
anything at all any behaviors any red
flags that pop in your head it's because
you're
insecure that is not true at all so
i asked and i don't think not true but
it's a load of crap i mean there's a lot
of people that are really
sick like singing those sound bites
these days
i've even seen a lot of academics
started starting this uh
i think you made a note about um
eroticizing your jealousy
yes um you know you might have heard
that sound bite but for men
it's like no it it doesn't work that way
it really doesn't
no and so and so for for guys we're
jealous
for because we want to protect our
paternity and that's a real threat
because we don't know
really i mean we do now with dna tests
but for most of our evolutionary history
we didn't know if that baby came out if
it was ours or not so they didn't even
have
safe reliable birth control until what
30 40 50 years ago
right something like that yeah so for
the most part we've operated without
birth control
yep and so guys getting cucked and
ending up with someone else's kid
meaning that their genes don't move on
to the next generation
is a huge existential threat for a man
it makes a man feel
violent and it makes a man want to solve
a problem real quick
ask yourself if that silverback gorilla
that beats up an opposing gorilla sends
him on his way
to protect his prized women his little
tribe to make sure that gorilla doesn't
mate
with his women is that gorilla insecure
are we going to have a
you know a psychological uh session with
him and talk about his male
insecurities of course not that gorilla
is as alpha
as any gorilla could be protecting his
territory and so for men jealousy and
jealous feelings both
retroactive meaning looking at her past
as well as current opportunities
that is a protective streak that's a and
that's in most
and i have to ask this question because
i've had these feelings and i don't
consider myself
not a confident person and i've noted
that there's dudes some of the most
alpha guys i know
have had that almost like abusive
jealous streak some of them
some guys who are real alpha like
putting their girl in line kind of stuff
which in a way that's not healthy i
don't recommend
and i'm like wait a second is that guy
insecure
is he asking question at what point
would you say that it's unhealthy
um i think that if you're having to
my my opinion if i have to create drama
in my relationship to keep her in line
rather than frame
i consider that unhealthy and so to take
it to another level
i'm using frame control in order to
you know influence her behavior which
means she voluntarily does
the mate protecting for me i don't have
to mate protect
for her if i have to make protect for
her there's no relationship in my
opinion
but that takes a level of frame control
and that takes a level of game in a
relationship that most guys don't have
so that's something that has to be
developed um
but yeah so i mean
anyways back to it it's not it's not a
weakness
you know in men and so that's a big
thing so men don't want to talk about it
and so what ends up happening is a lot
of maladaptive
or we could say bad or unproductive
behaviors that come out of this
the most unproductive one that we see
for most men is they
ignore it it's plausible deniability so
they do one of two things they
latch on to blue pill fantasies that we
call you know blue
the blue pill fantasy stuff she loves me
you know we said the magic words at the
wedding um
you know whatever she bought me this
cool thing for my birthday so
you know when she goes out with kevin
sales i got nothing to worry about
or when she was getting you know uh
let's try the sensor myself when she was
at the party in college and uh
you know went on a
uh ride don't think i have to worry
about that because she loves me
you know what i mean and so these are
things that you know they guys latch
onto that
and they try to ignore present behaviors
they ignore red flags because they think
that makes them confident
you